مع ساعات المساء الاولى اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عده احياء في مدينه
رام
الله قامت بالقاء الرصاص الحي وا قنابل
الغاز والرصاص المعدني على المواطنين
الذين كانوا يحاولون الوصول الى مناطق
سكناهم بعد يوم عمل طويل وايضا طلبه
المدارس يتم استخدام الليزر حتى لمنع
السيارات من الاقتراب الى هذه الاحياء
التي تعد الاكثر اقتضابا بالطبع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا منعت سيارات
الاسعاف من الوصول والتحرك والتنقل بل
قامت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا
بالقاء وابل من الغازات السامه في محيطها
وفي كل شارع ومنطقه حاولت من خلالها طواقم
الاسعاف الوصول ايضا الى الفت والشبان
الذين حاولوا التصدي لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بما يملكون من ادوات بسيطه وهي
فقط الحجاره بالطبع هذا الاقتحام ياتي بعد
يومين من اقتحام المدينه بعد ان كان قد
زعم الاحتلال ان مستوطنا اصيب عند حاجز
عطاره شمالي رام الله والبحث يتم عن
السياره التي تم استخدامها لتنفيذ هذه
العمليه وايضا الوصول الى منفذ هذه
العمليه ولكن واضح ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايضا تقوم
ب عطاب عدد من السيارات مصادره مركبات في
كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه خشيه قيام
فلسطينيين باستخدامها لتنفيذ عمليات ضد
اهداف اسرائيليه جفال المدير الجزيره رام
الله